precisamente en plena rueda de prensa
cariño jean pierre a la portavoz de la
casa blanca estaba informando sobre
diversas noticias nacionales cuando los
periodistas la interrumpió y le dicen
que efectivamente se ya se hacía pues
conocido y oficial el mensaje de el
reino unido sobre la muerte de la reina
isabel segunda al respecto la portavoz
de la casa blanca dijo que las oraciones
de los estadounidenses y los
pensamientos estaban con de la familia
real y los ciudadanos del reino unido al
respecto también nancy pelosi presidenta
de la cámara de representantes de eeuu
dijo que iba a ordenar las banderas
también a media asta en el congreso para
hacer honor a la reina isabel segunda
hay que resaltar que la reina isabel
pues estuvo 70 años en el trono durante
estos 70 años al menos 14 presidentes
estadounidenses pasar
durand estuvieron en el poder acá en
washington durante estos 70 años la
reina isabel visitó a eeuu al menos
cuatro veces de forma oficial y pues fue
clave en la guerra fría y en muchos
acuerdos comerciales y políticos que
eeuu y el reino unido pues han tiene en
este momento y han llevado a cabo
durante esta historia tan cercana que
tienen los dos países piden si dijo que
le dijo alice tours la nueva primera
ministra de inglaterra que hasta ser
recordemos solamente el martes se había
dado la mano con la reina isabel ii
había sido confirmada precisamente como
líder del reino unido pues yo bailé
habló por teléfono una llamada que tenía
también con otros líderes de estado y le
dijo alice tours que efectivamente
estaba haciendo el seguimiento cercano a
todo el tema de la salud
y por la que estén en fase de salud
porque pasó la reina isabel antes de su
muerte así que dijo también yo bailén
que iba a seguir y obviamente desde la
casa blanca le han dado todos los
reportes acerca de de la muerte de la
revisar el excelente harry truman era el
presidente de eeuu en 1952 cuando llegó
la reina al trono precisamente y
cristóbal mientras acompañamos esta
conexión vamos a ver en ese momento a
media asta la bandera del capitolio de
eeuu allí en washington decide donde
usted se encuentra vemos esas imágenes
en pantalla cristóbal la reina como
venimos contando era la jefa de estado
del reino unido que podemos decir acerca
de las relaciones entre estados unidos y
reino unido eeuu y reino unido países
con muy buenas relaciones diplomáticas
podemos decir
muy buenas relaciones diplomáticas
además se confirmaron en el reciente
acuerdo que el recién la reciente
negociación desde los submarinos que
firmaron con australia entre esta
australia el reino unido y eeuu hicieron
este acuerdo donde francia se vio algo
molesta porque tenía ya este acuerdo
pactado desde antes con australia esto
para darle simplemente un ejemplo de las
fuertes relaciones y de las estrechas
relaciones del reino unido con
eeuu
desde su anp que precisamente visitó
varias veces
el reino unido y todos los presidentes
que han además no solamente ha tenido
vínculos políticos sino también pues
inversiones y en intereses económicos
esta relación de eeuu e inglaterra se
reporta también a la estrecha relación
que tuvo reagan margaret thatcher
durante esta época pues se fue la época
fuerte del neoliberalismo y precisamente
estos dos líderes fueron los que
impulsaron este nuevo modelo
político-económico que a partir de
entonces a partir de tachó y a partir de
regan pues dio un viraje bastante fuerte
hacia la liberación de los de los
mercados a la privatización de los
servicios públicos de las empresas
públicas que muchos países en el mundo
pues copiaron y pues siguieron ese
modelo que thatcher y reagan fueron tan
vehementes en tratar de aplicar en sus
países esto tuvo grandes efectos en las
economías del reino unido y de eeuu y a
partir de ese momento
pues más vinculó a un ideológico
precisamente por ese ese camino de
neoliberalismo que empezaban a trazar no
solamente para el occidente sino para el
resto de países en el mundo que copiaron
un modelo parecido trataron de hacerlo